we have a lot to get you today lena
dunham lies again we're going to get to
the special counsel apparently opening a
grand jury we're going to talk about
Jeff Sessions the Attorney General
looking to crack down on leakers we'll
get to all of that this is Ben Shapiro
and this is Ben Shapiro shadow all right
so we do have a lot to get you today I
want to get to all of the stuff that's
really in the news the kind of main news
of the day but the best story of the day
is this story about Lena Dunham and I
would just be remiss if I didn't lead
off with it because it is so grand and
so glorious and she is such a terrible
person in every way this of course is
Lena Dunham the wildly unattractive star
of girls the reason that I point out
that she's wildly unattractive is
because she has said in the past that if
you find her wildly unattractive it's
because you're sexist um no it's because
you have eyes so Lena Dunham
apparently she's lied about a bunch of
things in the past she said in the past
the the star girl she campaigned with
Hillary Clinton she has said in the past
that she was raped by a Republican named
Barry not true she has said that she did
not abandon her dog she just was was
given a dog that had a history of being
abused also not true and now her latest
story her latest iteration in her
stupidity cycle comes courtesy of
American Airlines on Thursday Dunham
tweeted that she over to American
Airlines employees speaking about how
they believe that the transgender agenda
was terrible for children horror shocked
no they must be stopped it's just too
terrible she tweets out late last night
quote at this moment of in history we
should be teaching our employees about
Rove and inclusivity American air that
was worse part of this night everything
that she does is always about the drama
right ugh this the worst thing that ever
happened is she the worst part of the
night I can't I can't handle it and
American Airlines row back you have us
concern please meet us in DMS with your
record locator in details what they
really should have said is you have a
concern please see a psychologist as
soon as humanly possible and then she
started DMing with them and here's what
she said quote hi I heard two female
attendants walking talking about how
trans kids are trend they'd never
accepted trans child and trans mrs.
grose I think it reflects badly on
uniformed employees of your companies
you have that kind of dialogue going on
what if a trans teen was walking behind
them
it starts at home but jobs can set
standards of practice thanks for your
consideration so in other words there
are two women walking along talking
about when the hottest issues of the day
trans children right kids who believe
that they are member of the opposite sex
and these women were saying I would not
accept it if my child said that they
were a member of the opposite sex which
is perfectly rational since you
shouldn't really accept that because
your child is not a member of the
opposite sex you wouldn't usually look
for treatment and this idea that as a
parent you should accept this new idiocy
voiced Adhan Americans by leftist
society it's just dumb all the way
through but she says big sister Lena
Dunham no big sister the one who said
the cheetah ones pleasure to herself
next to 11 year old sister so she's not
just big brother she's big sister and
the best kind of big sister big sister
reports that to American Airlines what
if someone had been walking behind them
someone was and she was a terrible
person so she reported that and then she
said I wasn't flying American this is a
JFK and I was in a terminal with
American attendants an American wrote
back do you know what gate this was at
she said I was in the arrivals hall
coming from gate b32 baggage by the
Hudson News across from the wine bar
okay Stalin my god just reporting people
for having normal conversation in the
hallways at JFK like this is what this
has come to now it wasn't manifesting in
their behavior toward trans people it
wasn't manifesting and how they treated
any of the trans customers
it wasn't manifesting in anything even
assuming all of this is true they said
thanks for the info Lena we're passing
this along to our team to review and she
wrote back thank you and then she wrote
hash tag across from the wine bar so now
we're now like targeting and tracking
down anyone who has wronged think I mean
this is Orwellian garbage Orwellian
garbage number one these women can say
whatever they like even if they've been
saying stuff that was really
anti-semitic do you think that I've gone
to American Airlines and said you have
these two vicious anti-semites working
for you're like get over it get over it
it's a free country you may think that
people are terrible that doesn't give
you the excuse to destroy their jobs as
I said you know on Sunday which is aq a
as I said if it's not impacting how they
do their job it makes no difference okay
then there's a big and then she tweeted
for those who followed my airport saga
yesterday here's my takeaway these days
it's the little things a smile offering
a seat respect
you mean the little things like not
getting people fired because you're a
giant douche bag a human being like that
it's like the little things like not
targeting random passers-by who happen
to disagree with you on a hot political
issue of the day I mean God heavens
forfend if they had said they voted for
Trump I mean my god then Lena Dunham
really would have would have reported
them to American Airlines except there's
one extra wrinkle to this story as
always american airlines checked out the
story and on friday they told Fox News
quote we always look into complaints
from customers but at this time we are
unable to substantiate these allegations
so there is no evidence that any of this
happened at all and Lena Dunham once
again is just saying crap because this
is what Lena Dunham does to get
attention leftist I never give you
advice because I want you to continue to
be a giant fail but here's a piece of
advice stop associating with nut cases
like Lena Dunham if you want people to
take you seriously number one having
your little emissaries going around and
reporting people in USSR East Bloc Stasi
fashion when they say things you don't
like that's gross enough having them lie
about it or say it without evidence is
really really super gross and at this
point the fact that the left continues
to hang on to to Lena Dunham just like
to hang on to Linda Sarsour it's just a
monstered with the fact that they don't
care about middle America they don't
care about people who disagree they want
the heroes that they want and it doesn't
matter if those people are garbage heaps
those people must be upheld it doesn't
matter that Lena Dunham is a personal
dumpster fire they're going to continue
to label her just the woman of the year
amazing amazing stuff but that's just
another great story from the Lena Dunham
annals of joy okay in other big news
today bigger news obviously now there
are a couple of big stories that are
break from the first big story that is
breaking is that attorney Jeff attorney
general Jeff Sessions has now announced
a broad crackdown on leaks now there's a
lot of speculation that the reason that
sessions is cracking down on the leaks
is because you know the Trump is angry
with him and so he is trying to please
the President of the United States by
cracking down on leaks the truth is he
should be cracking down on leaks anyway
we saw a very dangerous league yesterday
when we saw that the Washington Post had
run on the front-page story that was
full transcripts from calls between
President Trump and the leaders of
Mexico and Australia as I said yesterday
that is super dangerous stuff it doesn't
matter that nothing really important was
said in those transcripts what had
happened if there had been something
important that kind of stuff should not
be made public especially because
America's enemies are looking for the
inside scoop on what exactly Trump is
telling our allies and our enemies so
that stuff is really bad obviously
sessions should be looking for the leaks
here's what Attorney General Sessions
had to say today first let me say that I
strongly agree with the president and
condemn in the strongest terms the
staggering number of leaks undermining
the ability of our governments to
protect this country just yesterday we
saw reports in the media about
conversations the President had with
foreign leaders no one is entitled to
surreptitiously fight to advance battles
in the media by revealing sensitive
government information no government can
be effective when its leaders cannot
discuss sensitive matters in confidence
or talk freely in confidence with
foreign leaders okay and then if you
continue that everything was he saying
there is exactly correct but it's the
latter part of what he said that is a
bigger problem so he now says that he is
going to start targeting media sources
for subpoenas about their sources he
actually accused the media of getting
people killed so he talked about this in
a long statement as prepared for release
he said we are here today to talk about
the dramatic growth in the number of
unauthorized disclosures of classified
national security information in the
past several months
this includes leaks to both the media
and in some cases even unauthorized
disclosures to our foreign adversaries
referrals for investigations of
classified leads to the DOJ from our
intelligence agencies have exploded in
the first six months of this
administration goj has already received
nearly as many criminal referrals
involving unauthorized disclosures of
classified information as you received
in the last three years combined this of
course is because they're a bunch of
Obama holdovers who are leaking
everything they can get their hands on
obviously that's criminal activity it is
also true that President Trump should
have moved much more quickly to clear
these bureaus and put in members of his
own staff it's ridiculous to leave in
place all these obama holdovers it's one
of the main failures of his
administration he says furthering this
goal we are here to announce some of the
steps being taken and underway by the
national insider threat task force to
ensure this government's first priority
to protect this country and her citizens
is not undermined by the very people who
have been entrusted to pursue this and
then he talked
specifically about what he was going to
do with regard to the media he said that
the media had basically got people
killed he said I've listened to career
investigators and prosecutors about how
to most successfully investigate and
prosecute these matters at their
suggestion one of the things we are
doing is reviewing policies affecting
media subpoenas we respect the important
role the press plays and will give them
respect but it is not unlimited
they cannot place lives at risk with
impunity we must balance their role with
protecting our national security and the
lives of those who serve in our
intelligence community of the Armed
Forces and all law-abiding Americans
that's some pretty harsh stuff and it's
some pretty heavy stuff and I think that
it's worthwhile discussing it for just a
second first of all should the media be
printing stuff that actually puts
American national security at risk of
course the media should not be doing
that but the media very often at least
the Washington Post in Yorktown from
reading they tend to take a general
level of care with national security
information so as not to reveal stuff
that would actually put people in harm's
way in fact the most obvious example
that comes to mind in the last six
months is there was that New York Times
report about how Trump had spilled
classified information to the Russians
in that oval office meeting behind
closed doors with certain Gekas lyac and
the Russian ambassador and Sergey Lavrov
the Foreign Minister of the Russia's of
the Russians and and if you recall the
New York Times actually said that they
were not going to print some of the
material because they thought that it
would hurt national security then Trump
promptly went out and basically blew
that wide open by omission by saying
exactly what it was that he had said
putting an Israeli national security
asset at risk the media obviously has to
be careful about what it leaks if
somebody leaks to you that we are the
new nuclear codes to give the most
obvious example and the New York Times
print the nuclear codes obviously that
would be something that falls into the
realm of endangering American national
security but we have to be very careful
just because we like attorney general
sessions or the Trump administration we
still have to be careful about the idea
that the press can be cracked down upon
to reveal their sources just because the
Trump administration doesn't like it or
nobama administration doesn't like it I
didn't like it when Obama did this Obama
famously prosecuted leakers he also went
after particular news sources that were
involved in in in releasing the
information from the Lakers this is
dangerous stuff we do want a high level
of transparency when it comes to
American government obviously if you're
working for the government
you shouldn't be leaking but going to
press outlets and trying to force them
to reveal their sources because you
don't like the information there's a
very thin line between trying to protect
national security and going after press
outlets because you just don't like the
information that's being leaked and I'm
not sure how much to trust the
Department of Justice with drawing that
line in a relevant and decent way I want
to talk a little bit more about that I
also want to talk about the big breaking
news obviously which is a robert muller
who's the special counsel has now
appointed a grand jury I want to tell
you what that means from a legal
perspective before I get to that I want
to tell you about the United States
concealed carry Association so last week
in Las Vegas a woman was beaten nearly
and just beating the crap out of her
boyfriend when she went to flee she was
followed by her attacker in the ensuing
chaos a bystander intervened and shot
the guy saving her life
eliminating threat to the community but
when the cops showed up they did what
they're supposed to do they arrested the
bystander he was arrested for being good
Samaritan this is the all too common
reality for people brave enough to
defend themselves and others and it's
not the fault of the cops and it's not
your fault but you could get caught up
in a situation where you are now being
criminally prosecuted or investigated
simply for using a gun in self-defense
this is why you need the u.s. CCA you
SEC is an invaluable resource for armed
Americans before during and after a
self-defense incident and they know the
police aren't always able to make a
judgment call immediately following the
event sometimes the law just precludes
that that means that even if you're
involved in a self-defense incident a
pretty good chance you'll be arrested
well an investigation is concluded even
if you're innocent so don't leave your
future up to chance go to defend my
family now calm let's defend my family
now calm to discover what the u.s. CCA
can do for you right now as an extra
bonus new members are automatically
entered to win a free gun so not only
will they provide you all the
information for after a shoot and get
you information about training with the
gun you can even win a free gun when you
go to defend my family now calm defend
my family now calm and the details are
all over there defend my family now calm
that particular deal and soon go check
it out defend my family now calm again
you don't want to be caught in a
situation where you're spending hundreds
of thousands of dollars on legal bills
and three years in legal system without
knowing what it is you're in for that's
why you need the u.s. ECA and that's why
you ought to go look them up and defend
my family now dot-com okay so the other
big story of the day is this breaking
news that the Special Counsel Robert
Muller has now impaneled a grand jury so
what
exactly does that mean while means a
couple of things Andrew McCarthy over at
national view who's been all over this
he says this is officially a criminal
investigation now you don't impanel a
grand jury for a counterintelligence
investigation grand juries are
essentially it's a group of jurors who
are set up in order so that they can
issue subpoenas for documents and
testimony with the power of law that's
what a grand jury does it doesn't
necessarily mean that the grand jury is
going to indict but you set up the grand
jury so that they have the power to
compel testimony and the power to compel
documentation the next logical step is
in indictments if they find some
elements of guilt now what is this grand
jury actually going to do well it's not
going to be investigating Mike Flynn so
Mike Flynn the former national security
adviser there's already a grand jury
that's been impaneled in Virginia to
check out Mike Flynn which suggests that
there are other people who are now in
the line of Robert Muller's fire
according to CNN
federal investigators explore and
whether Donald Trump's campaign colluded
with Russian spies have seized on Trump
and his associates financial ties to
Russia as one of the most fertile
avenues for moving their probe forward
according to people familiar with the
investigation so there are a lot of
people on the right right now who are
legitimately saying I think this is
correct
that this investigation has now
broadened beyond collusion they can't
prove collusion and so now they're
looking for other criminal activity that
is not within the scope of the
investigation it's not within the scope
of the investigation and Trump is now
stuck between a rock and a hard place
because if Muller exceeds the scope of
his investigation if he's no longer just
required to restrict it to Russian
collusion now it looks like he's just
looking for criminal activity every
which way he's just looking at every
nook and cranny for criminal activity
and that would be an excuse just to get
Trump out of office by the Democrats now
if Trump fires Muller is going to look
like he's trying to obstruct something
if he doesn't fire Muller there's a good
shot that Moe comes up with the
prosecution of some ancillary official
in the Trump campaign and the Democrats
use that as a brickbat in order to Club
Trump into submission it's a rock and a
hard place again this is why it was such
a mistake for Trump to get a special
account so appointed in the first place
it was it was his own fault if you
recall back to the firing of James Comey
the only reason a special counsel was
appointed in the first place is because
the Attorney General had already recused
himself on Russia the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein had not but Trump
used rod Rosenstein as an excuse to fire
Comey and then Comey
leaked out that the that Trump had
basically threatened him
at least according to call me and then
Rosenstein was now implicated in this
whole thing and then Trump went on
national TV and said he really fired
call me because of the Russia thing
using rod Rosenstein as cover enforcing
Rosenstein to recuse himself and appoint
a special counsel so Trump is stuck
between a rock and a hard place
according to CNN the FBI is reviewing
financial records related to the Trump
Organization as well as Trump his family
members including Trump jr. and campaign
associates they've combed through the
list of shell companies and buyers of
Trump rented real estate properties
scrutinized the roster of tenants at
Trump Tower reaching back with more than
a half dozen years this is exactly the
kind of stuff from said he didn't want
if you recall back to New York Times
interview two weeks ago from said if
Muller starts looking into financial and
propriety then maybe I'll fire him which
would trigger not a constitutional
crisis but certainly a major
constitutional conflagration again it's
not a constitutional crisis because
there means to deal with it but it would
certainly create a firestorm it would
look a lot like Nixon trying to fire the
special prosecutor in the middle of the
Watergate investigation and again Trump
could do this even if he's completely
innocent but it would just look bad
Trump attorney Jay Sekulow is openly
stating now that there's no reason to
think Trump is under investigation and
an inquiry from the special counsel that
moves beyond the mandate might be a
reason to fire him this is not a
surprise because the impaneling of a
grand jury in situations like this when
you've got an investigation is typically
how they move forward that that's that
is really very much a standard operating
procedure when you've got a situation
like this but with respect to the
impaneling of the grand jury we have no
reason to believe the president's under
investigation here okay so they're
they're suggesting still did their
separation with Trump and this is true I
mean we don't have any information
that's not true the problem is that
seculow has had credibility problems in
the past just in the last week it was
revealed that Donald Trump was
intimately involved in the crafting of
Donald Trump jr. statement about the
Russian meeting from 2016 and seculow
had gone on national TV and said as you
recall that Trump had not been involved
in the drafting of that statement so
there's credibility problems all the way
across the board this is going to be a
thing that just dogs the Trump
administration and this is the problem
you know because Trump kept talking
about it because there all these leaks
coming out and the leaks are truly
egregious you know special counsel
should not be leaking because of all
this it's just a dark cloud on the Trump
horizon that he can't seem to get rid of
and if you fire smaller then that
actually accelerates
now the media of course have been have
been suggesting that this is the be-all
end-all now there's a grand jury that
means Trump is going down a lot of
wishful thinking in the media and it's
driven the left a little bit nutty to
the point where they now suggest that
Trump was intimately involved that he
was in bed with Vladimir Putin again
without evidence I thought the Kellyanne
Connolly did a good job on CNN pointing
this out in this case now again I think
people are just talking about an
investigation that exists but looking
for collusion and conclusions that don't
exist and I like the fact that CNN took
about almost a full week off slinking
away from covering the Russian so-called
investigation because you know that the
polls say that 6 percent of American
states the most important issue to them
but that is consumed 75 percent of the
coverage so I do think Americans are
owed full coverage of all the issues
they say effect in the economy jobs
health care certainly national security
and the like and I hope that your
network will continue to do that well
you know we try to cover everything that
matters and sometimes yeah I'll kind of
- Kellyanne there shellacking a piece of
wood Chris Cuomo who is a living
embodiment of a tree he must think of
him when he was in high school nor can
we need someone to play the tree Chris
step forward and he plays a fantastic
oak pine is mediocre but his oak is just
absolutely terrific so well done Kelly
uncomely this is the problem with it
with the media on all of this is that
the media have declared that every
element of the case means the Trump is
guilty so they matter what happens the
conclusion is Trump is guilty the grand
jury doesn't mean that Trump is guilty
it doesn't even mean that we know that
anything is wrong here's what we do know
at this point
apparently CNN is saying the
investigation is focusing on four key
figures it's exactly who you would have
thought exactly who you were thought and
who I've been saying for months we're
going to be the people who are involved
right if there if there was involvement
Paul Manafort who is always in bed with
the Russians okay they're suggesting now
that Paul Manafort was being targeted
because investigators had found
conversations among alleged Russian
operatives regarding manna forts
attempts to encourage help for the
campaign from the Russians that would be
the collusion that people are talking
about
with manna fort Trump has a good answer
to that which is I found out about it I
fired manna for the problem is that he
didn't just say that up front he should
have just said that up front and and
then he would be
in the clear a Carter Paige who's a
foreign policy adviser and Trump is
under investigation apparently he's been
under FISA surveillance since 2014
which means there's lots of records of
his conversations and of course Roger
stone the political operative who is
very close to the Trump campaign does
any of this mean the Trump is guilty no
it doesn't mean that any of it doesn't
mean the Trump is guilty and if you're
actually going to find evidence and
let's see the evidence but I think that
it is a it is a problem for the for the
Trump administration to suggest that
nothing is wrong and it's a problem for
the media to suggest that everything is
wrong I want to talk a little bit more
about this plus Trump does something
pretty great and it demonstrates the
movement of the country that has not as
much to do with Trump as it does the
movement of the country toward a redder
country in terms of the map but for that
you're going to have to go over to Daily
wire comm 999 a month will get you a
subscription to this the greatest show
in the history of humanity it will also
get you the video show you can see the
rest of the video live be part of the
mailbag will do live mailbag questions
today and we are going to be doing the
mailbag so if you want to be part of the
mailbag subscribe right now and you can
have your questions answered in the next
15 minutes make your life just
inestimable better and if you want the
by the way you also get a michael knows
the show which is climbing the charts at
itunes what are you people doing it's
like number 11 and news and holidays
what is wrong with you people but but
the show is climbing the chart you can
get that and get Clavin show as well
nine nine nine a month gets you all of
these magical things plus for the annual
subscriber fee of $99 this the greatest
of all tumblers the tumbler that came
straight from the hand of God
the leftist here is hotter called
tumbler it's actually if you go back and
you should look in the Sistine Chapel
this is actually in the Sistine Chapel
right when God is leaning over to to
give Abraham his humanity I actually in
his hand is this leftist here's hot or
cold mug it was with this object that
man was created the leftist terrorist
Hydra called mug you get that for $99
erode annual subscription no orbit just
wanna listen later please go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud
right now by the way if you go over to
iTunes and leave a review then you can
continue to to show the rest of the
world that the show is climbing in the
transmitter now number 14 in the nation
in all podcasts overall and we are
number four in news and politics so you
can make us continue to to grow by
leaving a review and subscribing we
always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so the other big news that happened
yesterday was at this Trump rally the
West Virginia governor who's a guy named
Justice that's really his actual name is
justice and he Jim justice which is just
a great comic book name but he does not
look like a comic book character
unfortunately that'd be awesome but he
does not he looks like a governor from
West Virginia and he was a Democrat he
was a Republican then he was an
independent then he was a Democrat and
now he's converting back to being
Republican and he's doing that because
he has principled agreement with
President Trump no he's doing that
because West Virginia is turning red
just like an enormous amount of the
country is turning red there are just 15
Democratic governors in the entire
nation at this point 15 in the nation
with 50 states Republicans are dominant
across the country
well I can't they get anything done you
ask because they're stupid but here is
Jim Justice declaring that he is now a
Republican apparently his own staff
didn't knows they're going to be kind of
disappointed but but here he is
announcing his shift I've been to the
Oval Office twice in the last two or
three weeks I've been there to present
an idea on coal and an idea on
manufacturing I've had the great
opportunity to be with our president
[Applause]
now let me tell you just this I have to
be really serious with you just a moment
I have to tell you that the last session
of our legislature I tried with all my
soul okay so he's a he's obviously happy
moving that direction because both
houses of his legislature are Republican
in West Virginia so it's now a United
Republican dominated state in West
Virginia so add another one to the
Republican column as well and the he
also paid homage to Trump which is what
you probably have to do in West Virginia
State the Trump I believe won by about
forty three points image to blow out in
West Virginia let me I'll have to check
that but in any case he actually said
there's nothing to this Russia stuff
right anytime you're in Trump's presence
you have to say there's nothing to the
rush of stuff and just as sort of a
points of homage and then Trump jumped
on that bandwagon to again I'm not sure
this is helping Trump's case too much
you should really just be quiet and let
everything take its course and then
defend himself when the time comes but
from decided to go up on the Russia
stuff too promising chance of you
guessed it because we will never escape
2016 2016 is now the time loop we can
never escape 2016 is a black hole of
human time and we will forever be sucked
into its maw reliving the death of
Harambee over and over and over as well
as the 2016 election it's like Groundhog
Day all over again it's time to chant
lock her up because the Russia story is
a total fabrication it's just an excuse
for the greatest loss in the history of
American politics that's our liberal
what the prosecutors should be looking
at our Hillary Clinton was 33,000
deleted email
[Applause]
they're all chanting lock her up I mean
it's you know everybody very
enthusiastic matram again we're never
going to escape 2016 here's the thing
until we escape 2015 we can't actually
move forward with a Republican agenda
instead we're just going to keep
reliving this thing over and over and
over and trump's just going to keep
talking about russia as a distraction
Russia is a distraction but the
distraction isn't from Hillary Clinton
okay the distraction is from your agenda
I'd say listen we could be moving
forward unpopular legislation that helps
Americans accept the media and the
Democrats keep focusing on what is a
giant nothing burger they have yet to
show a shadow of proof of actual
collusion right instead we're going back
to Hillary Clinton I understand this is
a cheap throwaway line I understand
listen if you want some carton
prosecuted his Attorney General can do
it but I don't see him ordering the
Attorney General to reopen investigation
into Hillary Clinton because it's just
another one of these throwaway lines
okay so what this is causing with regard
to Trump all of this is real causing
with regard to Trump people on the right
to go to this place where everything
that Trump does that is bad is justified
by some of the things that Trump does
that are good and on the Left everything
Trump does is awful and evil and
terrible and garbagey and there's no
in-between so greg gutfeld
who has been at times a I think a rather
well calibrated critic of President
Trump's yesterday he's talking about how
Trump lied about the Boy Scouts cause he
said that the Boy Scouts were were
calling him to give him the best speech
ever and in Gutfeld basically says I
don't really care if he lies if he gives
us what we need about the ends of rally
itself is you can see how how Trump's
persuasion works what he does there when
all this other stuff is going on he
focused on the everyday issues he
brought up taxes crime drugs care jobs
coal the Paris Accords these are things
that are major concerns for people and
what it does is it marginalizes by
comparison the obsessions of the media
whether it's about his language about
his meetings about his bids about Jim
comes off as superfluous irrelevant
because all the people if you went up to
somebody there and you said yeah but did
you hear their impaneling they go I
don't give a damn you know what I have a
problem with oxy I got problems without
you caught coded in my society I
I'm glad he's destroying Isis bringing
okay and so the one out there this is
this is the right-wing line the right
blue line has become I don't care about
the Russia stuff because he's doing
things that I want him to or least
talking about things that I want to do I
have other concerns and the left-wing
line is I don't care about Trump's other
concerns with the people's other
concerns because of the Russia stuff
that the Anna Navarro is line overrun on
CNN here she is saying that yesterday
the real story here is that you have the
Prime Minister of Australia having to
explain policy to him like you teach a
four-year-old how to read a is for Apple
B is for boy c is for cat the President
of the United States was completely
ignorant and clueless as to the policy
that they were discussing it was crazy
and using it was painful I mean let me
just say this and I've been saying this
all along
please do not gauge your level of
political participation knowledge the
stuff that you care about my president
Trump if you're on the right don't gauge
what he's doing wrong by what he's doing
right and if you're on the Left don't
engage what he's doing right by what
he's doing wrong don't pretend that he's
universally one way or another don't
pretend everything he does is great
don't pretend that his his sins are
excused by his good deeds that's not how
it works and on the Left don't pretend
that the stuff that Trump is doing that
some of what you like is is stuff that
is somehow antithetical to the American
Way because you don't like the rush of
stuff instead where you put Trump aside
and say okay what is he actually doing
wonder why we all try to do the same
things we all try to do the same thing
at least we can exist in the same realm
of facts the problem is we no longer
even tell the same narratives you look
at the headlines at Huffington Post it's
Trump lies about Boy Scouts and then you
and Trump lies about Russia and then you
hover to Breitbart in the and and it's
Trump succeeds in West Virginia with
coal I mean it's like two separate
worlds that you're living in and never
the two shall make we have to keep both
of those things in our mind if we're
actually going to create I think a
relatively reasonable and an objective
and useful picture of the presidents of
the United States and how well he is
doing okay time for some things I like
things I hate that I want to do an extra
special mailbag today so the thing I
like today we've been doing Anthony
Skinner Meucci all the way through the
week this actually isn't a movie that I
like a lot I don't like the movie very
much but this is the Anthony Skinner
mooch in a nutshell I just I had a hard
time
by Nahum guys I mean I got to be real
about this Anthony Skinner Moochie was
my favorite character in Trump the
series and it makes me really sad I mean
just the way that I felt terrible after
the red wedding and Game of Thrones and
I just kept thinking god that was
terrible what they did to Rob you know
now I just think about Anthony Skinner
motion I think what would he be doing
with this news cycle you know w WASD
what would Anthony Skinner Moochie do I
you know I just think that every so
often it makes me sad for it yeah I I
said earlier in the week that we
shouldn't mourn we should just be
thankful for the time we had together
with Nancy nice killer Meucci but you
know it's in line that people stay at
funerals and then two days later they
feel terrible because they remember the
person's not there anymore that's how I
feel about Anthony scaramouche you know
every every few days I just think and I
think back and I go man that guy that
dude then Anthony Skinner Moche dude so
this of course is from American Psycho
the most the movie that I think most
closely resembles Anthony Skinner
Moochie it's not a great movie it's a
cringe inducing horrifying movie
Christian Bale plays this Wall Street
guy who's the yuppie and has gotten
sucked into the power games of yuppie
dumb and then is driven totally mad by
it he's a sociopath who murders people
and he decides to murder this particular
particularly guy has a nicer business
card than he does and so he decides that
it is relevant it is worthwhile to
murder him while listening to Huey Lewis
and the news it's been compared to Elvis
Costello but I think here we have a far
more bitter cynical sense of humor the
average trip yes Alan why are the copies
of the style of section we played you
even dog
whoo-chow or something no Alan is that a
raincoat it is in 87 can we really live
for the most accomplished album I think
they own disputed masterpieces
it to be where chantel passion most
people probably don't listen to look but
they should but it's not just about the
pleasures of conformity and the
importance of friends and also a
personal statement about the band itself
the movie itself is terrifying and
insane and you left at the end with the
you don't know whether Christian Bale
actually did any of things whether it
was all in his head but I think that's
that scaramouche in a nutshell
everything is sort of over-the-top and
crazy and he may be an axe murderer I
just don't know enough about him at this
point well maybe maybe one day we'll
find out and you just don't know okay so
time for some things I hate them we'll
get to the mailbag okay so the first
thing that I hate is a Colin
Kaepernick's girlfriend came out
yesterday America Colin Kaepernick he's
the guy who used to play quarterback for
the San Francisco 49ers until he started
becoming incredibly crappy became a
second string quarterback and then
decided to kneel for the national anthem
cratering a lot of the NFL's ratings and
in destroying a lot of their credibility
with non black communities and I say
that because the polls showed that black
Americans like the the national anthem
stuff and non black Americans really
didn't Hispanics and whites really
didn't in any case Colin Kaepernick's
girlfriend tweeted out that being a
quarterback in the NFL was like being
owned as a slave okay if that's if that
is the way this works I mean I make
myself a good living here but if that's
slavery and boy sign me up
because the slavery is being paid a
hundred million dollars like some of
these quarterbacks are I mean Colin
Kaepernick's I'm like a twenty million
dollar contract and he was an awful
quarterback he's a garbage quarterback
who couldn't read a play he couldn't
even look you can't even check his
secondary receiver my goodness and he's
making millions of dollars his
girlfriends weeded out that if you are
warm with the owners of a team that's
because they are like slaveholders and
you are like a house negro essentially
Steven Naismith says that all that's
happening here is the NFL was trying to
silence future Colin Kaepernick's and of
course the god the execrable Max
Kellerman
who I cannot stand the worst host in the
history of mankind for any purpose ever
okay Max Kellerman there's a show in LA
a sports show in LA called Max and
Marcellus it is legitimately the worst
in the history of humanity if satan
could have crapped out a show it was
down like Massa Marcellus it is the
worst show ever so anyway with that
ringing endorsement in his years here is
Mack skeleton with Steven Naismith
talking about how Colin Kaepernick is
obviously being victimized last point it
goes deeper than that and here's why
because far beyond the importance of
winning what you're trying to do by
keeping Colin Kaepernick out the game is
not just silenced him but silenced all
those aspiring to emulate Colin
Kaepernick it's a dissuasive measure
being exercised by League owners
regardless of what they're willing to
admit so if they way with this where
Colin Kaepernick is kept out of the
league and there is no noise that's
reverberating then you know what they're
going to succeed and the suddenly you're
going to hear a lot of folks being very
very quiet and not speaking up about
issues and that would be tragedy that's
right right which is agency tragedy if
Colin Kaepernick couldn't kneel for the
national anthem
other people might think twice about
kneeling for the national anthem that
would certainly be tragic I mean not
that there any consequences or anything
to the NFL for for all of this but if we
dissuade athletes like we're you know I
don't know whether Steven Naismith was I
honestly don't know where Steven
Naismith was when it came to Curt
Schilling basically being thrown off of
ESPN for implying that Isis and the
Nazis were part of the same sort of
general mentality about Jews like I
don't know where Steven Naismith was for
that I don't know where Stephen H Smith
wasn't Mike Ditka got kicked off the
network for suggesting that he was going
to vote for president Trump I don't know
where Steven Naismith was when Chris
Broussard was suspended because he said
he wasn't personally in favor of
same-sex marriage during the Jason
Collins stuff but this idea that the
dissuasion can only be practiced against
the the right and that Colin Kaepernick
should feel nothing like it you can't
even disagree with him look if you're an
NFL owner why would you put a guy who
made himself wildly unpopular with NFL
fans on your roster particularly when he
sucks by the way I promise you that a
Colin Kaepernick were really a terrific
player he would still be playing in the
NFL I promise you that right now okay I
got criminals playing in the NFL
perfect example Steve Nash right
terrific point guard for the Phoenix
Suns and is with the Dallas Mavericks
and then who is also with the with the
LA Lakers briefly Steve Nash if you
recall he's Canadian and during the Iraq
war he refused to to put a hand over his
heart
for the American national anthem he
wouldn't stand for the American national
anthem exactly the same as Kaepernick
during the Iraq war
did he play again yeah because a good
player so this idea that Kaepernick is
not being hired because of his politics
no Kaepernick is not being hired because
he's not a good player the same way that
you know for all talked about a Tim
Tebow was not hired in part because of
his politics but I think largely because
it wasn't a very good player he was a
much better player Tim Tebow would have
been in the NFL still okay time for the
mailbag so let's do that Lorraine right
hey Ben how did you become so good at
argumentation did you actively study it
are you simply very well-informed on the
topics you speak or both thanks well I
think that arguing is a tactic you know
debating is a tactic so number one you
have to feel comfortable with your own
positions really have thought them
through thought the information for real
really feel comfortable in debate and
stick and move and be able to move with
people that's that's the best way to be
good at debating but you also have to
study the debate tactics of the person
against whom you're debating so when I
debated chanc Weger I still remember
names last name but Jin Cheng tiger over
at over at poetic on on Sunday I had
studied his previous debate I looked at
how he had done it with an action and in
the past actually the debate ended up
being very different than those debates
but I was prepared if he was going to go
low I was prepared for how to counter
that if you decided to do that so every
debate you have to have a game plan for
I would say that every every argument
that you have in public you should have
a game plan for Benjamin writes hey Ben
I'm Ben well congratulations dude today
I was scrolling through my Facebook and
saw post and infuriated me the post read
like this don't call transgender people
mentally ill if you believe a man in the
clouds loves you unconditionally but
only under certain conditions the
implication of course is that all
religious people are mentally ill how
would you respond to this things I would
respond by saying that's ridiculous the
reason that's ridiculous is because
there's no evidence that religion is
mental illness there is an is a belief
system ok people believe lots of things
lots of people believe in secular human
rights there is no basis for secular
human rights ok it's based on your own
logic my belief in God is based on my
idea that there was a planner and
creator for this universe and that God
is intimately involved in the continuing
in the continuing fate of man because I
believe that people generally as a whole
get what they deserve both here and in
the afterlife and I can give you all the
logical reasons why I believe that yeah
I will
we admit there are logical reasons that
go the other way I think the only
evidence-based position on God is
agnosticism that's the only
evidence-based position I'm God
because I think that you can make a very
solid evidentiary case for the presence
of God the idea that there was a
designer of this complex universe that
would be nearly impossible to comprehend
in in terms of random chance and also
in terms of why human beings would be
able to grasp at the essence of the
universe and uncover all of the secrets
like why why don't we all just animals
who basically move sticks around why is
that so that's a good case for God
freewill is the best case for God the
idea that you can choose to do otherwise
if you're a determinist and that's a
good case for atheism right so I think
there's evidence on both sides but but
certainly a belief system is not the
same as mental illness the reason that I
say it is mentally ill to to to if you
are transgender is because you believe
something that is objectively not true
you're objectively not a woman if you
are a man you're objectively not a man
if you are a woman things have
categories okay it is not objectively
untrue that there is no God
right I can believe lots of things and
as far as it as far as you know what God
wants of me I can believe that the
system that God promulgated at Sinai and
was then promulgated to the world
through Christianity more broadly I can
believe that that system of morality has
led to the greatest civilization in the
history of mankind by a wide margin and
that's relatively good evidence for it's
at least utilitarian value so again
trying to link belief systems with
mental illness again it's not
objectively unverified it's not
objectively verifiable that it is false
judaism christianity or presence of god
it is objectively falsifiable the you
are a female if you are male okay that's
that's the answer also if you want to
talk about why it's mental illness again
religion is linked to better mental
health actually religious belief
generally is linked to less depression
less suicide
what's drug use what's alcoholism higher
degraded happiness transgenderism going
to a 40% suicide led rate higher delay
to higher rates of STDs higher rates of
not just suicide but but depression a
higher rates of self-harm okay Adam says
hey Ben Orthodox Jews believe in Jesus
correct they don't believe he's the son
of God though right did the Jewish
religion believe he claimed to be the
son of God
if so isn't this blasphemy please
clarify what type of person Jesus is in
the eyes of the Jewish religion so or
that actually believed that there was a
Jesus and the Jesus existed historically
speaking what we believe is that Jesus
was another Jew and that he did not
claim to be the Son of God that that was
a later addition in the Christian
Gospels because Paul is writing 40 years
after the death of Christ and that's
what he sees Jesus on the road to
Damascus and that and that Jesus was
essentially attempting to lead a
rebellion against the Romans was killed
for his trouble just like a lot of other
Jews were killed for their trouble
that's the Jewish take on Jesus
obviously that's why we different right
I think Jews and Christians don't
believe the same things about Jesus
John's has been with all this talk about
health care why are we not talking about
the health of Americans childhood
obesity processed food diabetes heart
disease we are fast food nation where
and where when and where does the actual
health of Americans come into the
equation cheers John John such a good
question so every time the web says that
health care outcomes in the United
States are lower than health care
outcomes in places like Europe one of
the answers is America is a very diverse
place with people who eat lots of
different things and have lots of
different habits about exercise and the
fact is that if you look at Ithaca
similar populations in the United States
and Sweden for example between just
people living in the United States they
have exactly the same life expectancy as
Swedish people living in Sweden so these
two populations are not comparable and
it's worthwhile noting that because
otherwise you have a compounding
statistic that's destroying the
perception what health care is and what
it does in the United States from Kyle
says team urine or team daenerys in in
Game of Thrones I didn't know that
you're on had a team although I am
appreciating the goth rock you're on of
this year and I'm enjoying his like
rabid smiling at people that is that
that's the thing and definitely not
teams in eras I find her to be an
incredibly boring character highly
incompetent to her at her job she has
like she has a couple of jobs one be be
good at outreach sucks at outreach
terrible at outreach everywhere she's
ruled has been garbage it outreach
legitimately the only people who like
her are slaves that she freed
understandable but she's not exactly the
queen of popularity then she's supposed
to be this great war leader she blows as
a war leader she's awful okay the
strategy that she has undertaken in game
seven in season seven or Game of Thrones
as promulgated by supposedly the
wisest guy on the show Tyrion I don't
know where Tyrion got this great
reputation as an advisor I'm not seeing
it dude like you in marine you were
awful he was an awful advisor marine and
now he comes to to Westeros and he's a
similarly awful advisor again like seems
like a nice guy but not really good at
his job
Daenerys is a terrible negotiator she's
terrible at outreach she's terrible to
military and she happens to be I'm sad
to say a terrible actress so there is so
so not good all the way through okay
Kyle says hello Ben I always hear about
how America is severely in debt to China
is it's like owing money to a loan shark
for a bad gambling trip kind of debt or
is it more complex economic issue a
brief synopsis would be great love the
show so I think that people need to stop
mixing up trade deficits with debt so
the United States has a lot of debt to
China that means that China has bought a
lot of American bonds they bought a lot
of American bonds because the United
States has been financing its debt it's
public debt right the things that we
take out to pay for Social Security and
Medicare we've been taking out a lot of
that debt on the open market and China
has been buying a lot of those bonds if
trying to want it to sink the value of
the United States dollar
all they would do is kill our ability to
actually borrow more money and the way
they would do that is by reselling the
bonds put the bonds on the open market
flood the market with bonds and then
that would inflate the value of the
dollar right that's that's the danger of
trying to owning our debt there are a
lot of people who have this weird idea
that because we buy lots of products
from China that the debt that's not a
debt okay when you buy a product from
your local grocery store you don't owe a
debt you just bought a product okay they
made they made money off of you but you
make the product off of them in fact the
way that International Economics works
if you spend a lot of money in China
you're spending dollars can Chinese
people in China spend dollars on other
Chinese products no they don't use that
these do Ron right so they actually
would actually have to spend those
dollars back in the United States what
you've actually seen it's called it's
called the capital surplus the United
States with China has a trade deficit
but a capital surplus meaning the China
is investing much more in the United
States than the United States investing
in China this also happened with Japan
in the 80s and it was freaked out we
have a trade deficit because everybody's
buying these cheap Japanese tape
recorders oh no we're all going to die
okay and turned out to Japan end up
overtaking us as the leading world
economy no they collapsed in the 1990s
they're all buying American land
American real estate they have we had a
capital surplus with them trade deficits
do not mean debt and trade deficits do
not mean
you are economically failing you know
it's a country with the trade surplus
right now really a country with a trade
surplus Venezuela we talked about them
earlier this week they've a trade
surplus because they won't let anybody
ship goods and services into their
country what does that meant absolute
poverty people shooting dogs in the
streets to eat them okay Ben says hey
been a lot of Ben's watching the show
there's even another one in the mailbag
Wow it says hey Ben I must ask in what
order would you put God family country
so as a religious person that's the
order right God family country now what
you hope for and what you hope to create
is an absolute symbiosis between those
three things right where there is no
conflict where your country is not
infringing on your capacity to worship
God or your family which you are which
you have worked to mold in a godly image
is in countenance with the country this
is why you need a free country that
allows families to operate as they will
and worship God as they see fit this is
why freedom is necessary so when
everything is in alignment these are not
in conflict God family country but if
you were to ask me you know if my family
were to come into into conflict with the
country which one would I choose I would
choose my family because I mean it to be
fair I don't know that that is even a
hierarchy because it depends on the
values bottom line is values or values
so if my family was right outside with
my family if the country is right
outside with the country presumably but
if you're saying that you know where do
I think I have a more heavy stamp of my
values obviously my family I have much
more of a heavy stamp of my values on my
family than I do on my country but if
all that put aside this is true for
everyone okay everyone values family
over country which is why it's
imperative that we stop breaking down
into tribal groups and then using the
government as a bat to club other people
in the submission if we do that then you
are going to have a conflict between
country and family and that's going to
get violent pretty quickly Ben says why
are there legal issues presented upon an
individual for using their firearm in a
situation where it is needed doesn't
that in one aspect two feet the purpose
of owning a firearm is there a way to
get the cement to ensure the full rights
of our legal gun owners so yes so that
you can violate some laws but not others
in self-defense situation so for example
this is why you know I'm not a big fan
of gun laws if I own an illegal firearm
and somebody breaks in my house and is
trying to hurt one of my children I
shoot him
be prosecuted for illegal use of a
firearm even if I properly act in
defense of self or others that's why I
don't like a lot of these gun laws and I
think that they're really really stupid
as far as why you would be arrested in a
situation where you need to you seca
that's just because the cops can't tell
I mean if they walk in your house and
they see a dead guy on the floor they
don't know all the circumstances they
have to arrest you first off just to
ensure safety but you know obviously we
hope and pray that in a decent legal
system you are acquitted and not even
prosecute in the first place Elka none
just says shabbat shalom okay well you
too dude and enroll God says hey Ben how
is it the progressive tax system was put
into place isn't there something in the
Constitution that says the government
has to protect your property and not
take it away just because that's what
the collective decided yes so the fifth
amendment to the Constitution of the
United States has what people wrongly
call the eminent domain clause okay this
is the idea that the the government
cannot take away private property for
public use without just compensation
that's the exact language of the statute
Richard Epstein has a really good book
called takings in it he basically argues
that if you look at that closely what
that really means is the government
can't take your money from you for
public use without giving you an equal
amounts of services in return
so yes the in the income tax itself was
unconstitutional the progressive income
tax was unconstitutional the sixteenth
amendment is the is the one that that
legalized the income tax worst amendment
in the US Constitution and and yes the
constitutional framework never conceived
of the idea of this massive private in
this massive taxation of private wealth
on a progressively sliding scale okay so
we will be back here on Monday and I'm
sure there will be much more news
because the news never stops gang I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]